but you look at these different events
that take place and like I say I think
that this event in Brazil if it's if
it's true I at this point don't have any
reason not to believe that it is true
yeah I can't wait to see more about that
yeah to see really what what stands up I
mean is this is this all part of this
well you know this lockdown that we're
going through is just somebody know this
was gonna happen right because even some
of these groups that we're talking about
red flags and the government saying oh
they're gonna you know tell her buddy
that the UFOs are attacking us and I
kind of really chuckled at that Oh
Michael do that so I mean it's a long
reach but hey listen maybe this was five
or six months ago so when this event
happened I haven't called them I haven't
told him about the Brazilian thing at
all cause like see I told you what was
going on so I've kind of kept it from
them but listen at some point if it's
true I have at this point no reason to
believe that it's not it's gonna come
out and it's gonna be it will be
something worth of talking about and
whether they say it was a UFO or they
say something crashed there and the
military took it away is still gonna
create enough of a mystery that people
are gonna want to know yeah you know
you've got people there that are trying
to fly drones over the area they're
trying to take hang gliders in and see
where it came through the trees and
sometimes guys we're talking about I
heard that yeah yeah guys take talking
about do paragliding around that ground
it's certain to find more information on
so again like I said something
definitely took place you know it's just
how far do you want to believe and when
I again when I started asking the
questions to kind of turn over the rocks
I did it from a perspective of look I
know you guys are busy right now I got a
question to ask and you know half of me
wanted to believe this is kind of cool
yeah you know the other half the reality
says wait a minute
you know how real is this and and what
are they really going to tell you yeah
even when it's funny after the fact the
former chief of police there in Brazil I
sent him a quick hey dude I figured this
out Bouck told me that they're there on
site now with it lockdown and he replied
back to me Mike I didn't even know UFO
crashed here so so he again like I say
man he's he's retired he still lives in
Rio but I would figure that everybody
would know and maybe he did know he just
want to tell me that's why I didn't
reply back to you right off forget
yeah yeah because he didn't reply back
to me until I told him that I got the
information from the guys at BOPE and
then he was like I didn't even know a
UFO crashed here it wasn't like no a UFO
didn't crash here let me just go ahead
and correct this whole situation it was
I didn't know this event even happened
yeah
so I've kept it on my phone I go back
and look at every day even the day after
I had talked to the group here I called
the supreme leader and I said hey you
pull my leg the other day you be the
serious duties like why would I Mike I'm
telling you we were just sitting here
talking about it it's it's that amazing
and I'm like so you are being absolutely
you not pulling my leg it's not indeed
I'm not pulling your leg it's whatever
took place there it's real and it's
going on right now so again it's just
such a big news you know are we
approaching that perspective in our life
now I mean it supposedly happened so
many times with these crashes around the
world
they had one crash in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania that took place and I want
to say that the late 70s out in the
woods there and everybody kind of you
know played it off and no no it didn't
really happen yet you meet or you watch
a show that has the mayor on there he
goes yeah not only that I brought the
preacher with me because they said they
thought it was a plane that went down
and they wanted me to bring the preacher
out there to read her way there the last
will and rights but we got out there and
it was some kind of Bell looking object
that we'd never seen before so now
you're like well scratching him on it
what what are we talking about here
right so it's like I say I think the
phenomena is gonna get bigger
yeah I think that it obviously there's
got to be some truth to it I can't
believe that all these people are there
so there has to be while Brazilian Press
reports that no one reported these
objects to local authorities allegations
of loud explosions and gunshots the
Brazilian military Corps don't does that
mean Kord owning cordoning military
cordoning off the area and army
personnel arresting anyone trying to get
close to this supposed crash site have
taken over Twitter and the subreddit
aliens I mean you know again here we go
we've locked it down we don't know why
we've locked it down and if you get near
the place by the way we're gonna arrest
you
so it makes you scratch your head so
something is obviously going on there
and whether it's you know and why do
these aliens keep going to Brazil I
think it's probably quite personal
America in general it's as Brazilian wax
jobs that the girls but again you know
you wouldn't think about it you would
think are you kidding me why Brazil of
all the places you know why Alaska is it
so is it so desolate there that you can
come and go as you want I mean there's
there's places on the map now on Google
Earth where they say in in arctica
there's a an opening where these things
are coming and going every day hmm and
that oh yeah there's a there's there's
theories that there's aliens flying
around on laser beams inside the earth
oh yeah so I mean again whether it's
true or it's not true there's always a
little bit of truth to some of it and if
you go back and you start kind of like
okay well let's talk about the Egyptian
that's a again let's go back to the
Mayans let's go back to these guys who
were cutting these stones and moving
rock and doing things that were you know
I know you weren't doing with a hammer
and a chisel especially a brass tone
yeah you know so is it a UFO that taught
you head of this you look at the
pyramids and when you go inside the
pyramids you see all this beautiful
artwork that's in there well who the
hell was holding the flashlight yeah
what were they using to light the inside
of those rooms I mean it was it it
wasn't a flame right because you'd have
black soot all over the ceiling and
knowing that two of the guys I spoke to
that were both of these guys were
archaeologists and they had worked at
the pyramids they said the problem with
the pyramids is just like a cave that in
certain areas there's only limited
oxygen so you go back in these real dark
tight areas and they have to bring a
thing to make sure that the oxygen stays
at particular levels so he goes you
couldn't burn a fire inside the you know
just try to use this light to but you
just couldn't have the oxygen there to
be able to do that right fire wouldn't
burn so yeah so you're like well okay I
never thought about that that's kind of
interesting but again the so it bleeds
you right back to the whole alien story
again and trying to figure out what is
really going on how do these stones get
made why are they so perfect and they're
engineering how do they know this
technology and then you get the
Egyptologist or the
the ancient alien theory of theologians
that come out and say hey listen this is
really what took place but it makes you
scratch your head and you think well
isn't something from a phenomenal as
going on because you wouldn't be able to
do these events or or to look at these
things or to come up with the ideology
that you're coming with today right you
know who thinks about that [ __ ] so
scheana's wild Hill and on something's
going on it's amazing something's going
on me and like I say project disclosures
got it going on okay if you look at if
you guys look up the Lois Alice and oh
that's el0 ndo formally with a tip 18
that was a advanced aerospace threat
identification program really really
cool lots of information Lois Elizondo
now he's part of to the Stars tts a
company co-founded by Tom DeLonge what
from blink 182 blink 182 did he is easy
oh he's big matter of fact he came out
and said I want to thank everybody for
for now allowing this this uh stuff from
the Navy to come out because it's proved
me right yeah Wow yes he didn't like
that for a long time actually and he's
actually said some people come to his
house and told me shut his mouth about
some of the things he was saying in the
past kind of interesting yeah yeah
and he goes just because I'm this this
guy who's got a microphone that
everybody would kind of listen to you
yeah but they came to my house dumb hey
you should be talking about things you
know nothing about he said well I guess
I proved you guys wrong because
obviously here we are having this
conversation now
but that's amazing I guess that's crazy
wild [ __ ] unbelievable man so I'll tell
you another story real quick I'm at my
house I live up by the beach and I come
out one night to take a look down by the
water and I see this red light in the
sky and I'm kind of staring at it cuz
it's kind of unusual it's out over the
water and it looks like the same type of
red light you would see in a tower in
these blinking towers or radio towers
yeah yeah and so as I'm kind of watching
it all of a sudden it turns from red to
like almost like a star color and I know
it's then like oh damn there's three
more there just like that I wonder if
they're the same thing
well then another one pops up and all in
all 18 of them popped up and as I'm
trying to watch these things and trying
to throw what the hell am I looking at
here I went in the house I got my
night-vision real quick
came back outside and I'm watching these
things and these these what look like a
red long light turned into a white light
that hung there for about 20 minutes
look like a star and they started moving
down the beach but when they move down
the beach they actually turned into you
ever see these uh these Oh skin colored
synthetic gloves you put on the rubber
gloves latex love it was that color but
and they were kind of clear and on the
outside of had a light that went around
it
yeah and without the night vision on you
couldn't see this and one all of them
except one went down the beach this cat
she came over one over our house could
one of those Chinese lanterns that
people do for like memorials do you know
I mean there's a Chane layer for space
yeah and listen I tried to think of
everything but the strange thing was you
couldn't see it without the night vision
on what it looked like was look like a
dirty cotton ball in the air well maybe
cuz it was so far away the light was dim
don't you put the night vision on it
intensifies the light so you could
actually see it better from well there
but the problem is this thing was like
right over my house okay so it wasn't
like a long far distance away and so I'm
looking at this trying to figure out
what the hell am I looking at here I
mean so it's just one of those kind of
odd events I mean listen we went to me
and Danny went to arrange to go do some
shooting in Florida in Florida yeah yeah
what was that town Todd this is over by
it's in Brandon I can't think of the
little town the community we're in but
it's it's literally out in the middle of
nowhere it's middle of nowhere shooting
guns out here near I want to say it's
near like Bartow area
yes near Bartow its near um what it's a
little town that's right I can't thing
of the town I think of here in a second
but so we go out there to go shooting
inward and this is a place where we
bring special operations guys out we
blow stuff up and we can shoot and move
and you have to worry about
and so Danny when to come out and take
uh some video of us you've got a really
nice drone and sent this drone up above
the facility we're at and we'll say it
was a half mile to a mile up and I could
hear it yeah so we do all this videoing
as we come home that evening I go back
to I take this footage back to my house
and I start going through it I'm looking
for particular views of the gun we're
shooting and my peripheral vision picks
up like this dirty little ball of light
that I see in the video real quick
and so I stopped it I'm like what the
heck was that and I go back and look at
it I'm like wow check that out what is
that yeah looks like someone beamed a
golf ball at the drone or shot shot the
drone and it was like this big white
bullet coming right up literally that's
why I sent it to data Mike hey dude
check this out on these frames not the
frames I'd originally given him were
incorrect and so he went back through
any found him he goes oh yeah dude I
found it and so he would sent me a video
that we just witnessed and went through
it at a clip at a time yeah right here
and was able to pull that out at the end
of it I'm just sitting I got the drone
just sitting there hovering and then if
you go frame by frame you can see this
like white golf ball looking thing
coming right at the drone but it goes
underneath it but you can tell you
deftly redirected and then all of a
sudden these guys from the beyond
unknown show almost the same type of op
gun I don't we're gonna call it a light
a golf ball a beanbag yeah whatever that
is something they recorded the same
thing it looks about the size of it
probably bigger than what a golf ball
would look like flying that far away
like I say they tried to say it was a
bird they tried to say and even when
Danny had talked about hey somebody's
shooting at my damn drone yeah I'm like
dude I couldn't see it was a mile up
right over her head they this is like
two miles away there's no way they could
have shot at that from that distance of
two miles and even been that close right
and this is the video you sent me which
is somebody else and this is like the
same exact thing now what is this video
from this is from beyond the unknown
okay it's just guys doing science work
that looks exactly like water food that
was I mean that's exactly that's the
same but again it's odd that it's funny
that these are all drones that are
getting these this video yeah and I mean
and I think it's the sound of the drone
that's actually attracting these things
now you know what are they that becomes
the big question that thing came from
the sky high yeah the one the one on my
drone looked like it came almost just
directly at it Terral oh well no that no
I I think it came from the wood line
that down low and then came up high I
think you have still had the original
video of this yeah I do have it
somewhere
and check it out but again it's just
kind of those weird things were wait a
minute this was probably five years ago
we did this four years ago we did this
or five years ago for sure this video
that just came out is just now and these
guys are also picking it up on their
drones and then there's another guy that
was in Utah that was a doing work on the
oil fields and he was actually doing
reconnaissance on some areas for new oil
and one of these things flew out and was
the exact same thing and he was actually
able to put a speed to it which he said
it was thirty eight hundred miles an
hour
it had covered two miles in two seconds
and came up with a 30 hundred mile an
hour so he's like I don't know what this
is now the one that Danny videoed
initially like I said when you watch the
video you don't even see it
and I just happened to pick it up with
my peripheral vision because it's moving
so fast yeah and then oh very easily and
then as I went through it some more
there's there was even more that were in
the video so the average bullet
according to Quora travels 2,500 feet
per second around 1,700 miles per hour
so it shows you right there I mean again
that's twice the speed of the bullet
2,000 miles an hour faster than the
bullet so I you know makes you scratch
your head wait a minute that was like a
four frame I was like four frames that
thing went they came through the drone
shot there was like four frames we could
see that white thing coming through
right right so I would do the math that
that video clip was shot at 24 frames a
second so 24 divided by four is what
20:44 six right so what would that that
would be I'm [ __ ] terrible about like
I said I mean I just assumed that was
about the same distance about two miles
we were looking at right and that if it
and literally covered that now on the
video or the original video you can't
see it but when you could slow it down
and you start doing the math okay well
it cover you see to full speed I mean it
literally just kind of showed up as a
spot and also there was sixteen sixteen
point six percent of a second I mean
that thing was in the frame dude that's
crazy
think about how fast that is really and
how and the fact that we even were able
to see that thing and pull it up and
look at it and the fact that it showed
up now and two other TV shows on TV it's
the same yeah white the same golf ball
the same whatever it is it's the same
yeah and it gonna make sure you scratch
your head like okay what is this and why
would it care about what our drones are
doing which is just odd to me all the
way around even we viewed that the first
one there were more of those whatever
that is in there as well I could see him
yeah but it you get tied up with other
things and all the sudden reality of
life comes back yeah I gotta feed the
kids and take a bath yeah I wish I get
paid to search this kind of show
[Laughter]